per l'edilizia
ciao ragazze o ragazzi sue cure
dopo effettivamente un po dietro degli
ormai non faccio più ogni domenica però
ogni tanto sento quella mancanza di
incazzature
allora smash his smash hi matic i viola
va bene comunque stanno ancora ragazzi
io la cosa che voglio
ok va bene e non era femmine d'istruire
comunque la cosa che vi volevo dire
importante prima di appunto iniziare ad
addentrarci in questo di questo video è
più il siano e che effettivamente non so
se vi interessa ancora ma a me interessa
quei finchè non esce
cosa è successo
trecento finchè non esce non sarò felice
e sabato di happy louis ii lo stanno
ancora facendo lo stanno ancora facendo
sono convinto che uscirà penso molto
presto perché appunto il creatore dello
stadio e da e dalla vita che scrive lo
sto ancora sviluppando eccetera ma
secondo me prima o poi uscirà sperando
prima che il mondo finisca
la mia vita impone a me comunque sia è
io non smetterò di fare video finché non
riuscirà il pd su e quindi almeno quello
già sicuri che ci portiamo a casa c'è
l'ex co
bellissimo
mamma mia mamma mi ha comunque non ho
capito alla fine questo carattere di
tali ma come se me lo presti a lanciare
ma non è successa questa cosa vabbè spa
informa i boys primo tentativo così ma
no ma ci ho creduto sul
terreno tra schede bidoni di immondizia
band a little bird ok great ex lenart
hacker gold creator of the universe
voglio essere almeno creator of the
universe
ma il verde non c'era
manca poco di testa ma non ho preso io
che risultò prima di vincere sono
nuovamente un pagliaccio a prova a fare
un po di tuffi di testa non ragazzi
allora non so perché non so che fare in
spite con le furono montero bravo sai
quante ragazze o rimorchiato con happy
questo oppure non è più così attenzione
però
donne è
spesso è my boys forest green suarez e
dovreste verdi va bene cioè questo kcal
h
ma bellissimo persino un salto mi
servirebbe ancora capire un attimo chi è
che che si prende la briga di creare dei
livelli belli su yepes per questo mi
sono livello fatto bene qui c'è ancora
gente che ci mette la passione la passio
come me che ci gioco dopo 85 anni che se
il creato rifugio che non mi fa 8 stato
è veramente mi sento offeso e sempre
guardare fatto anche una bandiera con
l'ombra abbiamo lucia questi artisti
moderni che nessuno se li caga ma perché
alex levinsky 6 hubert selby
chi
già c'è un cap cos'è oddio
mi sono schiantato sul muro non ho
capito cosa è successo ma va bene c'è un
cane che vola qualcuna spiega c'è un
procione incazzato nero a l'ho colpito
mi sa che lui ha colpito me bigger
giorgio related ma perché era una cosa
di jojo
scusate non ho capito cosa c'entra
giorgio qua sono un cattivissimo fan di
jojo se non con coraggio geo rapper e
non lo sta cogliendo c'è un cane che mi
incorna dove stava giorgio reference
poltrona ndong va bene win
a c'era un ventilatore che vi sparava le
palle ok
madonna giocosi bellissimo e vedo perché
ci fanno vanno a caso le palle cioè non
è che sembra brutta frase però giuro che
non volevo no che è staccato sulla morte
un giorno forse facilmente francese un
caso che
c'erano tutte la morte ma non cadevo per
bellissimo modi per morire in minecraft
cosa c'entra questo è pista non lo so
blow up by a clip va bene sì ma non è
che devo morire anche io che sto sotto
c'è calcola le sue cose iniziano a non
ha molto senso prova bene usando una
sword contro uno scali
va bene
left clicca villager ma non succede
questa cosa ah ok perché ti attacca il
gol e non va bene mirare direttamente
sotto i tuoi piedi questa è un classico
anche solo scavarsi di sulla testa e ti
escono i come il suo amico dove lui
siano qui qui qui topini che escono
dalle rocce ma come cacchio è come
facciano ricordarmelo mai provando a
raccogliere la firewall del gas
effettivamente quello è un problema
al vil farefinder ska un'incudine che
cade dal cielo effettivamente questa è
uno dei modi più strani prove cadendo
sulle stalagmiti
e sono comunque riuscito a perdere una
spettatrice rigore in cielo in un altro
universo parallelo tanto non ero a
livello larice però abbiamo capito che
simone minecraft grazie alla ci sono
spiegato non sono bastate le volte in
cui sono morto io così e sono tante però
love
you would hacker e cracker cracker mike
hall gold libano nella notte difficile
amico mio non era così difficile ed
quake sim
simulazione di heart quake
è la o my brother madonna già spaccato
tutto compreso il mio collo per aver
contemplato e piuttosto casinò e non ho
capito effettivamente che senso
heartquake simulator io non sto vedendo
non darmi accettate zio anzi non
vuol dire non vedo terremoti cosa
c'entra terremoto sono io
dove stai vedendo il terremoto il suo
livello si non sto capendo o un accetta
né il tuo braccio attaccato al culo
insieme l'anguria nel massimo ma io
posso giocare da 10 anni a fare ancora
ste cagate siccome poor's com'e come
faccio a fare ancora così schifo sul web
invece impossibile
ok bella
yo yo yo yo ma dai
lo spaccato la radio in compenso voluto
tirare io la palla romy 6 giu cristiano
ronaldo
mi sono staccato due o mind dove
terremoto
che dovrebbe essere il terremoto
simulator
quella era la mina andavo con un
terremoto va bene forse mi salvo forse
o forse no the most easy jump
non lo so rick mi sembra falso
non lo era
non lo era pensa se cade se fossi caduto
il metodo di proviamo a fare l'ultima
ragazza speciale belle che non so cosa
sia speciale n jong pari va bene vediamo
alle belle made from my skull assis
sceglie i ragazzi a scuola si sono messi
a fare sta roba nicole wigan su andrè
brendan dylan bravi che durante le
essere giocata è pensa che lo faceva 4
informatica andiamo avanti ragazzi
benissimo bab el ma è veramente l'hanno
fatto per i bravi ragazzi se avete
veramente fatto avete un talento è
incredibile
madonna è impossibile sopra sta roba
hanno fatto proprio sentire ma voi siete
i ceo di internet ma veramente
complimenti ma ragazzi voglio conosce i
professori ma mettete i 10 us i ragazzi
non sono fenomeni l'hanno fatto a scuola
c'è ma cosa
aggiungiamo un po di difficoltà ma donne
raga
tv ajax sono tornati indietro non si sa
per qual motivo ti bum bum boxes
guarente che esplodono
è cascato un bidone totalmente a caso ma
va bene perché cascano pezzi di bidoni
bidoni ecco perfetto trash dei ok
è
testata bellissimo complimenti ragazzi
bravi carlo bandic mi avete sorpreso non
sto scherzando con quelle con i
complimenti spero che video di eccomi
signore vi sia piaciuto lo stesso giorno
come un bel mi piace anche ai soci che
vogliono trattare sfizio nel senso che
ci siete sempre ceniamo al prossimo vino
e ragazzi
[Musica]